é a criança bem aí se alguém que vocês
conhecem o lugar que conhecendo levanta
a mão fazendo favor bom
em seu lugar quem conhece pode repetir
quem só tem pouca gente conhece
não deu pra ver a gente pois bem né
este é o morro redondo um mirante
natural lá de poemas situada 1.000 224
metros de altitude do nível do mar é o
dobro da altitude no distrito na de
poema quando eu conhecer o morro redondo
a cerca de 20 anos ele era assim uma
imagem de abandono uma capela com portas
e janelas de metalão com estrutura
prestes a ruir
mas mesmo assim eu me encantei com
beleza nesse cenário todas as fotos que
eu vou mostrar a questão do redondo e
achei que merecia ser feito um projeto
de revitalização para transformá lo num
uma referência do turismo repórter lá lá
tem uma história religiosa mais de 100
hans dez anos depois eu residindo em
poema pode colocar parte desse projeto e
eu enganei esei que foi criação de uma
nova trilha uma trilha contemplativa uma
melhoria na igreja e fazer uma
revitalização da festa em santa cruz uma
festa centenária
aí a trilha
dois anos depois nós resgatamos um lado
de peregrinar como redondo
porque antigamente
ó caminhava até o morro redondo pra
festa de santa cruz que lá nós
comemoramos no início de maio
o ano passou a gente e no ano seguinte
com 11 rádio já que a gente não tinha
dinheiro nem sou boa vontade e ajuda da
comunidade
nós iniciamos o trabalho de construir de
anguilla uma nova capela que depois até
mudando o nome para santuário do senhor
do bonfim
lá é muita dificuldade em construir já
que os 200 metros finais
tudo tem que ser levado no lombo de
burro então não é uma tarefa fácil além
do dinheiro essas dificuldades de
logística então areia tijolo cimento
quando era levado um homem dos burros é
levado longe da gente mesmo
mas com a ajuda da comunidade era um
desejo da comunidade com o envolvimento
de todas as mulheres os jovens as
crianças
nós fomos construindo a realidade nesse
sonho é pra fazer isso nós também
precisamos muito da ajuda da internet
então eu criei um blog abraço ou
redondos que era nosso portal de
transparência
ali a gente pedir ajuda dos amigos ali a
gente mostrar onde o dinheiro estava
sendo empregado
além disso realizamos rifas realizamos
festas para ganhar os recursos pra fazer
estas e outras obras
entre essas outras zonas nós fizemos a
sinalização de poema ao redondo com
cruzeiros de quatro metros de alturas
todos em desenvolviment de linha férrea
escolhem esse material porque é uma
forma de reciclar é uma coisa rosca que
integrar bem com a paisagem da região em
um material natural respondeu exclusivas
são três cruzeiros que tem ao longo do
caminho o primeiro é de lado da igreja
de la mata de poema também fizemos um
portal usando recursos nosso lamento
as pedras do pão redondo fizemos um
portal ajeitada com o redondo e
[Música]
valorizar mais esse trabalho ganhamos
uma escultura do senhor do bonfim é da
artista plástica vilma noel
aí o texto do senhor do bonfim ser
levada lá com o redondo e é um espaço da
igreja
além disso gente ela doou pra gente um
outro trabalho uma escultura de dez
metros de altura que foi colocada do
lado de fora do morro redondo aí o
desafio de levar a escultura e parte pra
lá
sete homens carregando em um local
apertado muita pedra solta muita terra
toda hora eles paravam para respirar
eu estava registrando podia pegar o peso
que estava sendo fotografada era mais
importante
morreu sem fazendo história lá né
contribuem com a história inclusive na
faixa de agradecimento que nós colocamos
o nome dos doadores das obras nos
colocam inclusive com os burrinhos que
foram muito importantes nessa opção do
trabalho
às vezes a gente trabalhava até de noite
nós colocamos a ter luz na escultura não
poder trabalhar de noite a gente cumpriu
o cronograma aqui nós fizemos porque nós
queremos inaugurar essa obra em outubro
porque eu tô outubro é um mês que o
aniversário da cidade aniversário de
drumond
queremos dar mais esse presente pra
nosso querido município
a escultura deste ano pronto essa
escultura de cana aos clements nos
carregamentos eram os negros que residiu
em poema mais de 50 anos atrás
eles tinham a soja areia depois no
redondo ainda então naquela época não
havia na estrada eles levavam em lombo
de burro mola de caminhão para reciclar
e com essas lonas de caminhão e se
transformavam e foices enxadas olé
ferradura então por isso a estudante um
aro de metal com
com a arte é isso aqui uma escultura
tivesse um ar um arco de metal e na
primeira vez que ela tem lá no morro
redondo ela teve a inspiração de fazer
um arranjo mesmo as antes porque a
natureza lá inspira é voar tão mais
perto de deus é em outubro então de 2010
dez meses depois gente nossa sonho parte
do nosso som estava sendo realizado não
durávamos aí o novo santuário senhor do
bonfim inaugurada nos ali
a escultura o destino mas a obra não
parou a gente com essas dez meses
todos os anos nós fazendo alguma
melhoria no no morro redondo além de
estar dando a manutenção aí nós
construímos a confirmar nem sabor e arte
que é um espaço de apoio para a igreja
que a idéia é desenvolver o artesanato
na região e formativo cooperativo para
lá eles vendem os produtos lá em busca
do turismo sustentável
então eles podem vender o artesanato
queijo doce as coisas produzidas há
também fizemos um deck que além de ser
um espaço para contemplar a paisagem
a bela paisagem do espinhaço uma
cordilheira e também para apresentações
culturais relata se transformando um
ponto de cultura
tivemos também todo o cercamento do
clube por questões de segurança as
trilhas são sempre recebendo melhorias
esse envolvimento essa união é tudo foi
possível graças à união da comunidade
as coisas tem que nascer da comunidade
destaca também o trabalho dos padrinhos
cada cruzeiro tem um padrinho e os
exclusivos são todos enfeitados para a
festa de santa cruz
então é com muito carinho que as pessoas
chegam trabalham lá pra decorar
exclusivos cada ano tem um tema ano que
vem como tema com
são dez anos nessa caminhada que nos
garantam o tema será andar com fé eu vou
e faço light
hoje podemos dizer gente que o morro
redondo é assim uma referência do
turismo tempo eu já vejo que nossa
caminhada que começou há nove anos atrás
lá com 30 caminhantes agora reúne cerca
de 400 pessoas
lá é um ponto de fé é um ponto de
cultura é um ponto de admiração da
natureza volta pede a anulação ea
valorização da natureza e é essa
essa sim é a minha missão de meda
trabalhar para o desenvolvimento do
turismo promovendo o desenvolvimento
intelectual e social das pessoas
valorizando e preservado a nossa cultura
e nosso ambiente
eu divido com vocês ok compartilho com
vocês aqui para mostrar que tendo ou a
vontade que tendo união é possível
transformar uma casa é possível
transformar uma rua é possível
transformar uma praça é possível
transformar uma sociedade é possível
transformar uma montanha sem precisarem
da minha ajuda a gente conte comigo
mãos à obra vão junto transformar essa
poética é paneira muito obrigado